l'expérience de l' isolement voilà qui
nous parle depuis le kobe 19 mai lui en
a fait sa passion le spéléologue au nom
prédestiné
jean-philippe trou va passer 60 jours
dans une grotte du gard expérience
scientifique qui vise à mesurer les
effets d'un confinement total sur l'être
humain
rémy carton a rencontré le tourangeau
dans son camp d'entraînement de
saint-avertin sous terre forcément
bienvenue sous terre dans la carrière de
l'éco chevaux ou ont été extraites les
pierres blanches de tuffeau
caractéristiques de la touraine ce
labyrinthe souterrain jean-philippe trou
le connaît comme sa poche
ce spéléologue est en plein entraînement
pour une expérience hors norme dans cinq
mois
il va rester enfermé 60 jours dans une
grotte du gard objectif pour ce
géotechnicien de formation tester les
effets sur l'homme d'un confinement sous
terre et réaliser un maximum de relevés
scientifiques car les phénomènes qui
anime les profondeurs de la terre
jean-philippe trous les connaît par
coeur on voit donc des concrétions
nestalas tout parce qu'on tombe là comme
ça la pression s'est un peu anarchique
mais il ya des animaux au fond de cette
carrière tourangelle le spéléologue
installé un camp de base reproduction à
petite échelle du campement où il
réalisera son expérience donc là on
arrive dans un dans un camp de base en
tout cas un exemple de camp de base
qu'on
qu'on va utiliser pour le projet trabuc
exploration dans la grotte de trabuc il
sera accompagné par le spéléologue
patrick candela aguerris et entraîné les
deux aventuriers ne craignent pas
l'isolément des personnes qui seront le
plus peut-être traumatisés dans
l'expérience qu'on va faire c'est pas
forcément nous c'est les personnes qui
sont à l'extérieur on a on aura des
journées qui sont tellement de bien
prises qu'on n'aura pas le vraiment le
temps de se dire on est on est bloqué on
peut pas on peut pas sortir c'est pas
vraiment ça qui va nous qui va nous
faire peur à l'aide d'ordinateurs
d'appareils photo et de caméras
thermiques jean-philippe trou tentera de
comprendre comment se sont formés les
cavités où il passera ses journées et
ses nuits tous les dix jours il
transmettra des données physiologiques
et psychologiques à des chercheurs pour
qu'à la fin de l'expérience
la vie souterraine révèlent tous ses
secrets